all right welcome to the ddps seminar
everyone before we introduce our invited
speaker uh let's go over some rules and
Logistics uh not many first please mute
mute yourself during the talk but if you
have questions you can unmute and ask
questions or use chat room to post your
questions so that we can address them in
Q&A session at the end um second today's
ddps seminar is open to external AUD s
uh please no classify
discussions um and today's uh the talk
is going to be recorded and available in
YouTube channel uh in near future okay
that's about it uh now let me introduce
our speaker today it is an honor to host
Professor David B who earned his PhD in
2002 with uh HT banks at North Carolina
State University he was a post stuck at
the uh University of Michigan in
mathematics and joined the faculty in
applied math at the University of
Colorado in 2006 the core of his
research interests are weak form based
scientific machine learning and inverse
problems at the intersection of Applied
math and
statistics his research has been
supported by NSF NIH doe and DOD today
David uh will talk about a first
principles approach to understand uh no
no no um
sorry not that um he's going to talk
about the weak form is stronger than you
think all right um now let me um pass
the button to him but before that let me
ask a some informal questions to get to
know him better um my first question to
David um today's will be how have you
ended up where you are right now in
terms of career research and work
etc uh well thank you very much for the
for the nice introduction Yung Su um in
uh in answer to that question uh it's
been a bit of a meander so to speak I
started out uh doing inverse problems as
an undergrad I went to do optimization
and computational fluid dynamics and
then I kept trying to figure out what I
really wanted to do in terms of I know I
wanted to do applied math um and
eventually I ended up doing mathematical
biology because it seemed like the
questions were very uh messy and and
interesting that could be benefit a
great deal from bringing more uh
mathematics and applied math
computational methods to bear um and so
I went through the standard career path
got a got tenure and about about the
time I got tenure I started looking back
to see what had frustrated me what had
um you know just inhibited progress and
the thing that struck me was in in
biology in particular there when you
would create models which model was the
correct model um you know just parameter
fitting uh you know forward solver based
you know you basically guess a parameter
forward solve iterate your your least
squares function and so I I just kind of
got to thinking
let's try to think more about the
computational methods and the
mathematics behind uh like the nature of
model selection uh as well as you know
system
identification and so uh eventually
ended up uh working on this this weak
form approach um is is where this got it
basically came out of being frustrated
of of trying to fit parameters to
another biochemistry or or bacteria
model and them not working and this
particular
um uh method that we have come up with
and this this approach that we have come
up with has a surprising number of
applications in many different areas and
has really uh helped answer um some some
important questions that uh that have in
system identification uh they've sort of
been elusive for for a while and so it
actually has applications that are much
broader than than biology as now this is
why young Su we've been talking is they
seem to be uh relevant in computational
plasma physics and uh and such and we
started modeling there so nice nice um I
mean your your first FS LED you to a
Wonderful World it sounds like it's
worked out pretty well yeah nice nice
story um okay well the stage is yours
okay all
right okay well uh thank you again for
the um invitation here um so what I'm
going to talk about today is an area of
applied math computational methods that
has really it was something that was a
part of the initial flowering of
scientific uh computation and and
scientific Computing that began in the
50s uh specifically where some of this
comes from was the aerospace engineering
literature where they were of course
trying to identify parameters very fast
to for the for the new the new at the
time of course the the Jets that were
being being created um um and so what uh
what happened was there was a strategy
for parameter estimation that was
proposed and eventually discarded and
the reason it was discarded is is
fascinating uh and and this there's
actually some interesting parallels to
what's going on today in the sense that
uh where a lot of system identification
went was this the direction of let's try
to solve the differential equation or
the stochastic differential equation in
in some way and then we can compare with
data and use that process to estimate
parameters this is sort of a um there
there's a positive feedback loop here
where you need a bigger computer you
need to come up with more algorithms
there are perhaps more knobs to turn and
more tweaks to make to get all of these
pieces to fit together but then of
course you would like a bigger computer
so that you can do uh more of these
computations um there there's actually a
very I was realizing the other day
there's actually a very strong
similarity to the way that some of the
neural network uh uh literature has gone
in terms of there's more knobs you need
a bigger computer Etc and so what we're
doing here is we're going back to the
basics of uh of stuff that was developed
in the 50s and 60s on system
identification uh with the benefit of 70
years of numerical methods computational
methods advances and statistics um as
well as you know parallel programming
methods uh all of these seemed to come
together in a way that wasn't available
back when these method they were
originally created and I will and I'll
get going in just a second but it's just
the the overview the the core of what's
Happening Here is uh based upon the weak
form so we all we've all heard about the
finite element method that's a standard
method for solving a differential
equation and the the way that what we're
doing here is in essence taking the
finite element method but instead of
trying to solve for the equation we look
at it from a different point of view and
say what happens if we substitute in the
data that we have and then try to
estimate the parameters so it's sort of
the reverse of what you would normally
think of with a a fin method so that's
that's the core everything follows from
that that concept um and that was
originally proposed in 54 uh and
basically no one was working in this
area by the end of the century um and so
this is what we we've sort of Unearthed
here um okay so briefly here um so Dan
is the the who's a graduate student with
me uh and this a lot of this work
originated from what was in his
dissertation and so he sort of a
collaborator from day one on this uh
this direction here um and and the
research that we're doing and then of
course we have April is another graduate
student in the in the group uh and then
Nora and Rainey are two posts um Vana is
another faculty member in the department
who does computational statistics who's
been uh heavily involved in this also
since day one um and then Seth and Nick
and Moi are uh so Seth and Nick are new
graduate students and Moyes and new
postto but these are people that're sort
of co- advising and working with other
people on and all of the by the way all
of the codes and everything that
reproduce the results in here if you're
interested it's in the uh math bio cuu
direct uh on GitHub the project there
though it's kind of gone far beyond
being math bio but that's the what we
have Okay so let's uh let's sort of dive
into what we can do here and why this is
compelling so just as an example I'm
actually G to give you the punchline
first here um so here's the kot ceny
equation okay this is a uh well I don't
know if it's super well known but it is
a an equation that curs occurs in uh
like laminer flame fronts uh there's
applications in plasma physics um but it
is a particularly challenging one to
just to deal with of course because you
can immediately see you've got four
derivatives you've got a nonlinearity
here um it's challenging and so if just
as an example if you took this system
and you this was the data you had uh how
in the world are you going to be
identifying these parameters to make
things worse you can actually prove that
this is spao temporal chaos so any
numerical uh problems way over here at
Time Zero are going to cause you big
problems by the time you get to over on
the right side right it's just gonna
it's going to blow up on you and you
really want to identify these parameters
minus one minus one minus one right how
do you do that uh for these these
complicated problems if if you have data
like this well normally we think about
fitting Solutions of data you can do
some filtering things but at the end of
the day you're still worried about
matching the solution to data um of
course you have to worry about your
numerical discreation there's a you have
to turn uh maybe you could train a PIN
to do that very fast and do operator
learning um maybe you uh one of and
generally in the 50s and 60s they would
call this minimizing the output error
and now we just think about this as
matching you know the solution for
whatever W you've come up with as a
parameter matching that to the data
capital
u um there are natural questions right
do you have the correct model uh what if
something changed um do you have there
are you know a whole whole laundry list
of an entire sub area of Statistics uh
is ways that you can do to detect
correct model from test from just
statistical testing uh to cob Libra
discrepancies and the entire uh
information criteria world that came out
of that there's the basian world there's
more of the machine the computation
Computer Science World uh so there's a
lot of different ways that you can say
How would how good does the information
flow from data to
parameters um and usually the the
methods that people have come up with
you worry about you know robustness to
noise how accurate is it um what is the
computational efficiency how fast can
this be done and usually any method you
come up with pick two right you don't
get all three and so one of the things
that's been fascinating about this is
that there are ways in which we're
getting all three of these and here's
what the example I'm going to show so
with that kerot cinsky equation here
along this axis is the wall time to do a
parameter estimation here along the
vertical axis is the relative error of
the the so the the norm of the air
basically um and this is with 20% noise
on a spao temporal chaotic PBE and we're
and if you just try to do this in mat
lab you know depending upon the real
noise realization depending upon the
parameter initial guess you have um
which of course then you have to figure
out what your initial guess is uh you
can get anything between taking a second
if you're lucky all the way to hundreds
of seconds all the way from you know
basically 1% or so or to 10% error going
single digits error all the way up to to
hundreds and hundreds of percents error
so there's really this entire spread of
different uh output error methods that
just using standard OD solver or sorry
pde solver in mat lab to try to solve
these um there's a lot of knobs your
numerical optimization when do you stop
you know when do you iterate and what do
you truncate or sorry um when do you
converge turns out if you use what we're
doing in the weak form you get uh a very
straightforward linear algebra problem
uh that is taking less than a second on
a laptop
and you're getting you know the mean
here is really for 20% noise you're
getting far down here below 10% error on
these parameters which is quite
surprising uh that you're able to get
both the speed the accuracy and the
robustness to the 20% noise here okay so
hopefully this is uh uh this has wet
your appetite now and that there's a lot
of interesting things that are are
coming and you'll let me get away with
my cutesy title about the weak form
being stronger than you think but okay
so where does our story begin let's go
back to the 50s and I'll show you what
uh what they were doing so they would
say okay I have some differential
equation here in this case there was
Odes uh time derivative over here and
then we have linear and parameters these
functions here usually are coming from
the equations of motion uh various
physics based ideas the whole concept
that they were they were attempting to
do and then it sort of stopped working
on this area was take instead of solving
the equation let's take the equation and
plug the data in and so you can of
course create for every data point you
sample at U1 all the way to you can you
know you can evaluate it all these
features these FKS that you have that
are physics based um and then you can
evaluate a vector which is the
derivatives now of course you see I put
a little til it here because we know if
we start taking derivatives of data
especially if it's noisy that's going to
be a problem and they knew this too
right so they said all right so here's
the GW minus B let's try to identify the
parameters in at least Square sense
that's great if it's not noisy because
it's fast but it's very sensitive to
noise especially if you do finite
difference approximations here and even
if you do smoothing uh because the
problem is that you're basically
projecting your data not onto the
solution manifold you're projecting onto
the basis for the smoothing operators um
you can still get you know there's
well-known biases that will creep in
here which can be a problem if you're
trying to fly your
plane okay um so as I said you know
advances in output error methods really
uh this area did not receive a lot as
much development as as it could have um
and by you know the year 2000 it was
pretty much dormant um so that's where
we were for quite a while and then there
was a paper in uh 2016 in pnas that is
the Cindy method right the sparse
identification of non Dynamics and why
this has sort of resurrected this area
of you know the equation error looking
at the actual when you plug in the data
into the equation this equation error
approach is what uh what Steve brunt and
Josh Proctor and Nathan Kuts did was
they said okay um suppose we don't know
the right hand side suppose we say let's
consider a kitchen sink let's consider
all these possible libraries a huge set
of Library terms here uh and can we by
plugging the data in to this particular
uh Matrix here can we do again a
minimalization of the leas squares but
to look at the uh well let's uh let's
regularize it by doing sparsity okay so
the idea would be if you plug the data
in here
uh for say the diffusion equation the W
Vector that you want to identify is a
zero here a zero here a nonzero for this
term and then a zero for everything else
so that's the that's the sparsification
process that you want to do okay so this
actually um it's it's it's really
resurrected this area of equation error
um You can call it an operator learning
algorithm if you wish it's not quite the
same as what we think of with neural
networks but you are literally learning
the right hand side of an evolution
operation so it is kind of op what
you're learning you're just getting you
know the pencil and paper version of it
that you could then analyze if you
wanted to um now of course the problem
with the derivatives didn't go away
that's still there if you're doing any
type of finite difference approximation
it's very easy to see that the step size
in the denominator is going to you know
destroy the variance of this estimator
if you just make the assumption that you
have data plus noise and you try to do a
find a difference approximation on it
it's just not your your expect expected
value of the of this is just going to
blow up awfully so moreover uh what
about you know this independent of the
noise what if you have a shock wave and
you have data being taken on that well
your solution may not be smooth so
immediately we start thinking about the
weak form and so what happened was uh
one of the things that when we were
being very frustrated and I was being
very frustrated at uh looking at some of
these um you know model selection
methods and parameter inference methods
and if there was anything we could do
that would better uh it occurred to me
maybe we could do something with an
integral transform of this and then sort
of Dan said how about the weak form and
this is really what where this came from
uh and so if we look at this okay so
this is a more abstract version right so
here's your um using multi-index
notation so there's the just think about
this is the time derivative on the left
and this is whatever derivatives you
need and then these are potentially uh
nonlinear terms so that's that's the
form at least that's what I'm going to
restrict to right now we don't really
have to be that restrictive but um let's
just deal with this because it's easier
to to work through so the idea here is
you take your pte and of course you
interpret it in the weak sense so you
need a test function right now why are
we doing this well we're doing it
because we can pull the derivatives off
of the data and just by integration by
parts place it on the test function um
we of course choose test functions that
are compactly supported over a finite
region so you have you know zero values
and then you set it up with zero
derivatives at the end points and you
don't have to worry about the evaluation
part of integration by parts and you're
just pulling derivatives off of the off
of the the data itself we get around
that whole problem with the um with the
discretization and the finite difference
operators uh causing problems with noisy
data and this equation is the equation
so we're actually now trying to solve
for these parameters with a simply
transformed
equation now so what is what does this
sort of look like you can of course then
create your B Vector your G Matrix and
again you're back in the sparse
regression problem but now you're robust
to know it and that's really the core of
uh of what's what's happened here okay
are there any any quick questions so far
before because this is this is sort of
the core of what I'm going to build
on yeah any
questions you can unmute yourself and
ask hi professor I have a quick question
yes um could you please explain how
noise affects uh how the derivatives
affect the get affected in the presence
of a noise
I didn't understand that part quite
quite well so if you um so so here's on
this side well there's a Time derivative
here there's also uh you know first
second uh space derivatives or however
many derivatives you want as potential
Library terms that you could select for
um so so just as I mentioned so if it's
diffusion you only want this one right
you want to do the sparse regression so
you get that but the problem is you have
data which is the U right this capital u
is your data what happens when you plug
the data into the equation we're not
solving the equation we're completely
bypassing that that idea we are simply
taking the original an original equation
in this case we're making it a super
large because it's got all these
potential terms in there but you still
have to plug the data in to be able to
minimize this this least squares cost
function so it's a it's a residual of
the equation
itself and so the problem is how do you
do that if you have noisy data
is that answering your question y thank
you okay and there's another question by
Amit in the chat uh he's asking will
this work if you have first and second
time derivatives uh yes I mean so we
have gone all the way up to I mean
fourth rtiv are no problem I'll actually
show a uh plot later on where we nail
the fourth derivative uh fairly really
really
accurately yeah
yeah it's it's limited by the library
you choose so whatever Library you you
decide you need here um that's it and
we've done things all the way up to
hundreds and even a thousand terms in
the library you if you go too big like
if you decide oh well I want to have you
to the tenth power as a potential term
in the library you can run into
numerical problems where vectors that
are sort of super large dominate
everything and so you have rank problems
um but uh but you know then there's a
question of do you really need you to
the 10th as a library want to reject s
Library term you want to reject um
usually just talk to the physicist or
the biochemist or whoever you're you're
dealing with as far as what's re what's
a reasonable set and maybe go one above
that you know it's sort of a little more
ad hoc but it's still you just try not
to get too big for numerical
reasons okay all right I'll uh okay so
um right so again we're back to solving
this sparse regression problem okay um
so what do these things look like well
they're just test function they're just
test functions that are zero at the end
points and derivatives are zero at the
end points and then of course you can
take a derivative of the test function
instead of taking a derivative of the
data um and you can kind of squint at
this this is just a you know fi and F
Prime here and you can see this is
actually like almost a continuous analog
of a finite difference operator I mean
it's a negative of it right but uh but
that's that's really what this is doing
here is that integral transform is it's
not just uh smoothing the data like this
type of a kernel would be but it's also
a derivative smoother when after
integration by parts um so of course
there's all these these questions that
come up which are um at the end of the
day and this is the this is the
important part these are answerable
questions using very conventional things
in numerical analysis of numerical
linear algebra statistics that have come
out in the last 70 years um what's the
spectrum of these you know these types
of of analyses uh so there's like this
is something that is understandable from
one end to the other is sort of my my
point here um if you want to see the uh
sort of a brief uh sort of high level
overview we got an article on the front
page of s news uh in October had some
nice pretty pictures there but so that's
the the bigger picture here um but uh at
the end of the day uh this you know it
has been around for a while and I I went
over it a little bit in the in the S
news mentioned the the 54 articles um
but it's you know people didn't did stop
in 4 like they continued developing this
there's actually a companion AR um sort
of archive preprint that goes through a
lot of the mor citations and the history
of this and what people had come up with
was everything from trig functions to uh
various piecewise polinomial this is the
one that completely independently we
didn't know about this when we started
but this is the one we came up with also
um and then a variety of other people
using her meat polinomial uh there's
different frequencies of trig functions
uh and then there's something down here
with cooked kid Cas is cosine plus sign
uh and then this is basically using a um
heartly transform so there's a variety
of things people have chosen to try um
but we have some other ideas so uh yes
so there there's there's a history here
um but it was really dormant by by 2000
and and in the the archive preprint this
the companion for the I am news I I go
into this sort of what's what's
happening here okay so um let's see so
what what is possible now with this
method well the Lawrence equation this
is sort of everyone's favorite uh
chaotic attractor here um add 10% noise
to this and you get the red fuzzy bits
here um and in we can get less than 1%
err with 10% noise on this uh and do it
in I mean fractions and fractions of a
second and why because it's going
completely to the the realm of linear
algebra numerical linear algebra ma mat
lab is amazing at this right and I'm
just doing this in mat lab there's
nothing nothing super fancy about this
that's going on
um but the question is you know when you
think about model Discovery for say the
Lawrence equation how in the world can
you even compare I mean I'm able to
solve this uh threshold or prune the the
incorrect terms from like a hundred or
couple several hundred term Library get
the correct Lawrence equation get the
parameters with less than a percent
error in a fraction of a second whereas
if I tried to just fit this using a
standard system ID toolbox I I must
admit I actually did let mat Leb run
this and it ran for like a week trying
to fit and solve and fit and estimate
and it it never figured out what the
parameters were with 10% noise for this
amount of it just it took forever um so
that's great the so we have a whole the
whole paper in multiscale modeling and
simulation I did this on Odes and then
pdes we have a computational physics um
paper and you know this works exactly
not only the noise is is dealt with but
also the shock waves are dealt with this
is just Burgers right or this is Burgers
um and for several hundred of these
carpet pictures uh we can go all the way
up to 99% uh sorry what it 100% error so
that's you know basically the the noise
to Signal ratio um and you can end up
with 99% of those hundreds of uh
experiments we we correctly get that
there is only this term okay uh sure
it's not perfect two and a half percent
so it's not exactly of of all those
hundreds of experiments it's not always
exactly minus one but you know the worst
is two and a half% off which is pretty
nice um
of course K shinski same thing uh and
this this is now the equation Discovery
what I was talking about was the
parameter estimation if we assume we
know these three terms are here uh and
what's happening now is we go all the
way up to 100% error and 96% of the
equations of the experiments we
correctly determine just these three
terms F 30% air on the parameters but at
that point it's sort of you're pretty
happy that you've gotten the three terms
you want so and that's the max over all
the um over all the the runs we did okay
so what um what is what's where's the
magic come from like that's uh it's
interesting that you can just take data
and come up with an equation even if
it's noisy and if you look at the the
joural computational physics we have
other examples and I I'll talk about
those in a little bit but like you know
navir Stokes reaction diffusions these
are all well within the the framework
that we can deal with um so what is the
where does this come from and here's
something that was really fascinating
I'll talk a little bit about this later
also um and this was what we realized in
the MMS paper so this is just a
Vanderpool oscillator so it stand
nonlinear oscillator here um if you look
at a test function that's a piecewise
polom so you've got Roots at a and minus
a and then you have uh you know it's
it's sort of a compactly supported so
outside of you know whatever the so you
have your middle of the D of the test
function then outside of a or minus a
every place else that's all zero and
then we use that you know kind of just
shift the test function throughout the
domain to create our equations um but
you still have to choose this p right is
the power of the the polinomial one of
the fascinating things we realized was
for the no noise case if you crank up
the P you actually get the accuracy of
your OD solver like if you could do
better than this this will keep going
down um and we've tried this with higher
Precision things um and basically where
this is coming from is the fact that you
need to do these inner products right so
these are approximations of integrals of
course they're discret approximations of
integrals but here's the thing um we
were just using the trapezoid Rule now
the trapezoid rule has a superpower
right it's a superpower that if you have
a periodic function and it turns into
you know periodic with you do the
periodic extension uh you have basically
something that's ordered delta T to the
p+ one power is the error in doing this
regression here so this this residual uh
for the the left side you know minus the
right side basically uh you get order T
delta T to the p+ one so if you keep
cranking up
the order on the polinomial of your your
piecewise piecewise polinomial for your
test function you will get better and
better results because your numerical
error is going down in the no noise case
right so this is not something I'd seen
before in terms of parameter estimation
or equation Discovery uh this this is
sort of you know basically give gave us
an indication that maybe we were on to
something
interesting um and so what you can
actually do and we did this a little bit
later uh you can take that residual
which is of course you know GW minus r
uh oops that should be B not R sorry GW
minus B so that's the residual but of
course you know you can plug in the data
and for an arbitrary Vector parameters
um what happens when you take truth plus
noise well here's the interesting part
this is something you know just some
tailor expansions Etc you can break this
down into the part of the residual is
due to the noise so if noise goes away
of course then this term disappears um
the part of the residual due to having
the W not be correct so of course if you
uh if you plug in the correct W then
this is going to go away but then
there's this other term having to do
with the numerical discretization okay
and so what happened is it's actually
the numerical discretization that is
driving or that's dominating in this
case you know of course if you get
enough noise then uh this term dominates
and then of course if you're far enough
away from the true solution then that
term dominates but it was really
interesting this was this is numerical
analysis question at this point um and
so given the data uh we came up with a
um basically a for8 transform uh a
discrete 48 transform way to approximate
what the derivative what the error in
the um the integral is and the two black
lines are kind of you can bound where
the numerical error is and then what
this is also showing is as you increase
sorry the horizontal axis here is the
radius of a test function the vertical
axis is the uh error in the um uh
Whatchamacallit the error and the
parameter estimate and so you can see
that the the numerical it's the upper
bound black line the lower bound of the
of the numerics on that that integration
error and then as you add noise of
course the floor gets brought up so
green is a little bit of noise red is
more noise blue is a lot of noise um but
the important thing is what you can do
is you can choose a test function now
where which is a transition and it's
away from the numerical error into the
noise so you don't have to worry about
this term here or you can minimize the
the impact of that term and that's you
know that's what we we've discovered
this balance between noise and and
numerics okay um so another thing that
has been really interesting here is you
can also look at this if you have
something with lots of spectrum
frequency you don't just look at like a
local test function you can actually
look at a global uh perspective that am
I'm matching the Spectrum correctly so
if I have blue as the truth for
kashinsky noise is uh red is my my noisy
uh data that's added on top of that um
if I look at the the transform of the of
the data I can figure out um you know
try to figure out a region where the
noise is starting to uh um I want to get
rid of the noise above a certain level
and if I use that to pick my wave number
and I can then translate that back into
the choice of the test function uh and
the shape of the test function how fast
it's decaying um what you see down here
is is basically the fourth derivative of
data so the red is of course the so the
blue is of course the true true fourth
der true weak fourth derivative and then
the red is the noisy fourth derivative
we noisy the weak derivative weak fourth
derivative of noisy data and you can see
I mean I don't you can just they're ly
on top of each other right so they're uh
they're not perfect but it's um that
that's the reason that that term is not
a problem taking a fourth R of of noisy
data okay um one of the other things
that uh has been incredibly helpful is
and and this is one of the reasons I
think why if you naively plow ahead with
this method without thinking about
computational uh concerns you'll get the
wrong answer um so if you have 50% noise
on kdv so this is a court rate debr with
some solitons that are interacting with
each other uh the issue is if you look
at it you've got you know the time axis
is on the order of 10 the minus 3 the
space axis is order one and the value of
the solution is order three that six
orders of magnitude separating the
numbers in each of these cases if you
just plow ahead and form G without
thinking you're going to get a condition
number on the order of 10 to the 26
that's going to be challenging uh for
you know I double Precision floating
Point arithmetic um however if you
rescale these so that they are sort of
all on the same scale you can actually
drop your condition number 10 to the six
which is not perfect but it's much
better than it's it's basically matching
your your you know 10 the minus 3 to the
10 the three separation as opposed to
something that's just you know off the
chart awful and won't actually tell you
anything um so scaling is important to
make sure you you normalize things um so
what's the what's the the punchline here
well uh so we went through and chose a
whole laundry list of very challenging
pdes um gave them some reasonable
libraries uh with you know certain
number of non-zero terms emissive
Burgers Kinski kdv n Schrodinger navier
Stokes porest media sign Gordon reaction
diffusion so all things that exhibit
different kinds of shock waves uh stiff
systems SP rals you know oscillatory
Behavior chaos you know these kind of
things um nothing takes more than 75
seconds on a nice old creaky laptop from
over 10 years ago so I mean in some
sense it really makes sense right
because it's just a linear regression
problem you're just solving ax equals B
um it's it ends up you know it's not the
small system you do have to worry about
you know G is 11,000 by 181 in a
reaction diffusion system but it still
is to be able to correctly learn that
that is a reaction diffusion spiral way
system in 75 seconds seems very
interesting and as a compelling result
that if you have data like that would be
something to to consider you know sub
using this method on to see what comes
out of it
um so okay so that's all in the the
journal computational physics article
and again sort of what do you what in
the world do you mean by comparison like
if you're trying to do like some AIC
type comparison you have to propose all
different combinations of methods and
solve those pdes like it's it's it's
this is a completely different way to
think about model
Discovery okay so what becomes possible
so here's something that is really kind
of interesting uh we chose to look at of
all things cell migration and there are
actually some really interesting
directions you can go with this in terms
of well uh like even birds and drones uh
if you're trying to discover something
about how drones are what rules drones
are using to to fly and which directions
they're going this is actually a
framework that you can start thinking
about it so we chose cell migration
because I I have a project with someone
who traces uh basically take a sheet of
skin cells and then they cut away part
of it and watch the cells to migrate uh
into the wound and so uh usually there
are PD models uh that describe these uh
in terms of chemotaxis and other types
of uh um just traditional pte modeling
um what we did was a Cell by cell model
so this is interacting particle system
so you have what are the rules that the
cell is using this is an attraction
repulsion Force potential there's an
alignment potential and there's a drag
potential now we haven't gone further
than saying what is the functional form
of this uh this function here but that's
sort of pushing the phenomenology
question one layer further away from you
that then you could go to now the
biochemistry and say you know if I come
up with this shape of a potential for a
cell in terms of what it's using to
sense its environment and choose where
it goes you immediately have a more
concrete conversation with a with a
biochemist that talks about
this uh so what do these things look
like well um so to be completely Fair
there's a lot of artificial data here we
started with experimental data but there
were some you know these these
potentials are inspired by experimental
data we haven't we've just gotten some
new data sets that we're going to be
trying um but the idea here what we're
going to use which again was inspired by
now analyzing real data um this is a
attraction repulsion potential which is
basically saying the cell doesn't get
what do not want to get too close or in
in front of or behind the cells that are
moving they can hang out next to each
other in like a row that's okay and kind
of March forward in a row that's a
perfectly fine movement uh over here
it's saying that whatever the cell is in
front of it I want to align with that so
if I see a cell going like this this one
back here is g to try to follow it as it
moves in whichever direction it's moving
it could care less about what's going on
behind it so given that these were
inspired by you know the first pass of
data what we did was then we created a
bunch of artificial cells and here's the
thing that's really fascinating so we
made a heterogeneous uh mixture of cells
that had different potentials uh and we
let them you know run around that's all
the gray trajectories here so we assumed
we had gray trajectories then for each
individual cell we learned the
potentials for that cell and then given
for each cell so there was hundreds and
hundreds of cells and then each of them
had their own potentials we were able to
use a ad hoc classification scheme and
recover the fact that we had actually
put three different cell lines or three
different uh cell types based on their
potential behaviors in that mixture this
is just one um I don't think this is all
but this is a certain one of the one of
the cell types is the teal one and what
you can see here is that as the cell
moves along on the black is the data uh
we can learn those potentials correctly
that if you it's it's literally lying
right on top of it and it includes the
ability to do I mean this is a 90 degree
turn followed by 180 degree turn uh
based upon the nearby cells and you can
see we're pretty much nailing these data
correctly so we've uh we're we're
excited about some of the new data that
that we're getting to analyze from the
um from the lab um but this is the kind
of thing that can happen is now you can
say all right put down a bunch of cells
have them grow and now I can literally
based on their trajectories I can
discover what is the
subpopulations which is kind of uh the
the biologists were pretty excited about
this um and just to show you what it
looks like so here's three this is sort
of the subsets of the the gray um
trajectories here of all the cells and
we have you know based upon how well
that trajectory predicts which way
something's going you can actually you
know it's a it's a normally distributed
air you can actually separate and say
okay if I use the wrong model they're
over here and here's all the right model
match to the the cells and so they can
literally be split into into
subpopulations that are of different
cell
types um so let's see uh yeah so this
was three cells one of the things that's
interesting here is that these were
completely unlabeled trajectories so we
didn't go in saying oh I know that this
is from this cell type we were they were
completely not no knowledge about them
aside from they were coming from an
interacting particle
system okay um the whole idea here is
we're trying to build a framework that
would be foundational tools uh for
biological digital twins right I mean
the whole the the next step in the in
the funding that we have what we're
doing is with these trajectories we're
also then uh my collaborator can label
certain Pathways inside the cell so now
you're going to be able to learn an OD
for each individual cell that describes
the biochemistry as well as the
interacting particle system so how it is
choosing which way to go and so you're
now coupling biochemistry with
mechanical uh taxes and
movement okay all right so that's one uh
one application uh another application
as I I kind of showed a little bit of
this in the beginning is parameter
estimation uh and so why this is
different well so here's the thing if we
have uh the basically Matrix G which has
data in it times the vector W parameters
we want and we have the vector B which
has also data in it this is uh you know
yeah you can just solve the normal
equations right this is what we learned
linear algebra very very simple and
straightforward the problem here is this
is not a traditional ordinar Le squares
problem you have to think about this and
you have to be very careful because you
have your data is corrupting The Matrix
and the vector
and the picture that shows you this is
this normally we think about you know if
you just put a straight line through
something you have vertical errors right
that would be like errors just in B
problem here is that we have both errors
in the horizontal and the vertical
Direction um if you notice if you know
something about the ratio of uh errors
in in the different terms then you call
it a totally squares problem and uh this
is a very wellknown and well studied uh
Gan goab has a bunch of papers on this
the totally squares numerics um but
that's a different issue so so the way
that we came up to do this is
effectively if you look at the residual
that of your truth here it's actually
normally distributed but you need to
know the parameters to get the
co-variance so we have an iterative uh
updating scheme just reweighting the
co-variance uh is sort of our first pass
at this um create some Matrix here the
important thing is that when you do this
you have to do a tailor expansion to get
this what you need in here is a Jacobian
of your library okay so all these other
things this is bookkeeping uh you know
if you have number dimmensions of of
variables Etc here's your test functions
choices the important thing is buried
down in there you actually need to know
the derivatives of your library terms
and then you can get an accurate uh
estimate for the parameters and the
co-variance that comes along with that
so just an example here this is pitching
aumo so this is just a standard
oscillation OD from Neuroscience if you
do traditional nonlinearly squares where
you do forward s guess a parameter solve
check guess a parameter solve that kind
of thing you're over here because you
have so many knobs that you need to turn
the tolerance of the solver the trunc
the the stopping criteria for the
optimization all these things uh and it
can take hundreds of seconds just for a
simple um OD with 5% noise whereas you
know the difference between in time and
this is horizontal axis is time vertical
axis is air again the difference in this
time and this time is probably did you
hit reload on your email and check it
right because that's uh that's what you
can do and you're talking about you know
seconds or fractions of a second
depending on how you Cod it up um and of
course you know yeah there is a
difference in the the specific errors
you get out um but those are that's
realization based right it's uh the
specific noisy data that you have and
where was it where was it
noisy okay um one of the really awesome
Parts about this is that since you are
living back in um statistics and
regression world uh you get sort of your
ukq on the parameters for free right
because it's just
you know what's inference on the
parameters you can get you know
obviously the this is sort of a scaled
covariance Matrix but you can say uh
what's the you know relationship between
the various parameters that's all part
of traditional
statistics okay so one more uh
application here which uh is what um is
part of the mimic the department of
energy uh proposal that the center that
we're uh that Young Sue and I are part
of and here's two examples from that
because now when you have this idea of
sparse regression um you know maybe it's
maybe you have an equation and you know
the hamiltonian and all these things but
at the end of the day what if it's so
complicated that you can't do anything
with it so what we've been looking at
here is reduced order models and so what
you see on the left is a reduced order
model where the hamiltonian is being uh
maintained basically so you're taking
some higher dimensional system and
you're collapsing it in this case I
think it was a nonlinear couple
oscillators in eight Dimensions this was
collapsed to four so you're only seeing
three of the variables but there's
actually a fourth one but what's really
nice is by doing that process there's
still some knobs you can choose which
scale you want to look at while keeping
your your hamiltonian more or less
accurate so the um basically the
original curve is this black line which
is bumping around in in this phase space
and you can see there's sort of
oscillations and a scale that's going
into and out of the screen and then
there's a larger scale oscillation going
around this orbit uh you can choose your
scale such that you either are stuck
here and you can just be on the fast
scale you know oscillating here or you
can choose the lower longer time scale
um to go around the orbit where you've
collapsed in that direction and this was
published this summer um the other place
you can do reduced order model is a much
more computational thing that is what
came out of uh of young Su group with
this latent space Dynamics uh inference
identification um and so so this case is
where say you want to train your model
so this is these are two parameters
related to the initial condition for uh
solving I think this is uh 1D or 2D
Burgers um and you can train your uh
basically your compression your auto
encoder if you want or a pod uh whatever
you want train it on the black squares
which are parameter combinations but the
question is can you create a reduced
order model where you can pick a
different arbitrary parameter in this
Grid or or elsewhere and get a correct
uh the correct uh reduced order model
that then you can expand back to the
full order model and but you're doing
all your solving on the reduced order
model and so here's the thing is that
the original way of dealing with uh with
ldi uh this this lat space Dynamics
identification um was to use well
basically ordinarily squares combined
with finite difference operators from
the sort of plain vanilla Cindy if you
use the weak form Cindy it turns out
that you can get it down to the
resolution of your projection operation
and these are you can't really see the
numbers here sorry they're like three
and 4% which is basically as good as
it's going to get based upon the auto
encoder and or the the Pod projection of
using only so many singular values um
and so of course you know even and and
here's the thing 50% noise on the
original data you get down to a model
that's giving you 100% speed up and only
5% error in your predictions so it's um
it's really quite compelling in terms of
how it can help okay um let's see so I
want to make sure I get one little thing
in here the really awesome part about
like this this is actually something
that has really been quite um
interesting for us and and just just we
can actually say what's the class of
models that in the limited Continuum
data we are basically with probability
one ASM totically we will recover the
correct model and so you have ASM totic
consistency in the model learning
process
so if you have a model which is uh on I
mean uh this form right here so linear
and bilinear the the highest power it
can be is quadratic and an individual
variable and this is a huge number of
different uh all the equations I've
shown today all fall in this category um
if you if you try to learn it and you
learn the wrong model add more data ASM
totically you will be able to get it and
we have some some results that say uh
exactly what that looks like so um it's
end so there's like a critical noise
level stability tolerance so this is an
all a a I don't want to go too long here
but we have a a very nice theorem that
is coming out in IMA numerical analysis
um that Dan did some amazing work with
the the concentrations of the
probability here um and basically here's
a picture of what it looks like this
isn't kerot cinsky it's uh kind of close
though and it's uh it's got things like
six derivative so it's sort of of the
same ilk this is the picture of the
solution where X and then time goes up
and you can see it very quickly gets all
sorts of messy and chaotic um this is
kind of what a test function looks like
and so we're kind of taking that um
magnet that's smudging magnifying glass
and kind of passing it through the
domain to create our large linear system
to solve and this is of course what the
noisy version looks like as you more or
less uh go from left to right here
you're adding more and more data a
higher resolution of data in here uh
you're sort of decreasing the step sizes
in T and X um and what you can see is
that you know for the highest level
noise so noise ratio one so 100% um you
can't do it on a test function that is
uh the the data is 13 by 13 that's too
small but by the time you get over to
100 by 100 you're really starting to rec
the probability of you recovering this
model completely correct uh in the terms
is approaching
one okay and so of course you know for
less noise then it's easier to recover
the correct
model um and then so we have this and
this is surprisingly a huge fraction of
mathematical physics uh fits in this
category uh so we can we can discover
many many things there's um there are
there's we even have some corollaries to
this uh where if you add extra terms
like trig functions you'll still get the
correct recovery it's just going to be
biased as the parameters but you'll
still have the correct
terms okay um
okay then in uh the last few minutes
here I want to talk about forthcoming
work um so this is what I showed at the
beginning we've got parameter estimation
pdes that's sort of in progress um
there's another angle on this that's
also uh in progress but really
fascinating because there's
one kind of big landmine sitting in the
middle of this that is an important
feature that needs to be uh addressed
and it's that you need to have data on
all of the variables that are going to
go into this equation error okay so just
as an example if you wanted to to
estimate parameters or learn equations
for a um epidemiology model right you
don't get to know the number of people
who are susceptible every day during a
pandemic you don't get to know the PE
number of people who are infected and
asymptomatic maybe you have some guesses
in terms of the data but you don't you
don't have a really good what you do
have are hospitalizations you have
really good data on people every day you
can get a census um the Department of
Public Health would would have that and
so the question is how do you use these
methods and I mean here's another
example where you're giving somebody a
some therapy in the blood you can
measure the blood and see how well it's
working but you can't sample somebody's
you know liver or other organs to see if
the Drug's getting in there but you can
write down a differential equation model
uh and then you know some okay I can s
samples on the blood and what you do is
use some tricks from uh differential
algebra to reduce this to an equation
just in the observed variable and then
you can do things and so this is just a
plot showing actually if you have the
noise increasing in your blood samples
you can still get pretty good um
estimates of the parameters of k12 k21
and and the sort of uptake
numbers so there this is sort of work in
progress we're trying to basically solve
that problem uh using some some Nifty uh
differential algebra
tricks um okay so time summary so you
know I think about this more broadly
speaking as operator learning we're
learning the form of the equation uh and
that is our wcind algorithm that does
that uh parameter inference is we're
calling it Wendy we perform estimation
of nonlin Dynamics and we are um really
excited because we are actually getting
a lot of these race properties of
robustness accuracy and computational
efficiency and most important so there's
two things the computational efficiency
uh you can run these things on laptops
so this is really fast um if you choose
to do this on a GPU you can actually
recast um a step in the middle as a uh
one layer in a convolutional neural
network and you can actually get another
order of magnitude speed up simply
because of the embarrassingly parallel
uh feature of of doing that and so
actually you've been running it on a GPU
goes even faster not because you're
using some uh Network or anything just
because of the mathematics of gpus and
the way they work with the the cores um
one of the things I'll mention before
the end here uh there has been a nice
ecosystem that is started to develop
around this there sort of become an
awareness that the weak form is really
uh this this has some compelling uh
noise robustness results and so uh even
in the group at the University of
Washington they have come up with an
alternative strategy uh which is called
ensembling that get that helps with the
noise um but it turned out it was
fascinating if you did the weak form the
ensembling that was actually the best of
their uh of all their methods in their
paper um there's even some people at MIT
doing mixed Inger optimization uh
there's ways to improve the sparse
regression Sun Kang at Georgia Tech is
leading group been doing some of that
there's even some really nice
theoretical results uh basically casting
this in a reproducing Colonel Hilbert
space and the W Cindy algorithm is sort
of projecting in a way that is is
accurate Etc um and then one final thing
I'll mention which I thought was really
really fascinating that I this is a
paper I just saw um there's a group in
California at the uh um at basically
City of Hope I think is the the research
center down in Southern California um
and they were taking Dynamic MRI images
and recovering uh spatially varying
profusion coefficients that may not
sound that may not be confusing is why
is that interesting well basically if
you give somebody a uh some sort of a
tracer or a contrast uh and watch it
peruse through say a tumor those are
going to have different profusion uh
parameters than a uh than the
surrounding tissue and so you're you're
very quickly able from Dynamic MRI
images to reconstruct exactly where a
tumor might be and so this is some uh
this is a really interesting uh
application they're using our method to
do to do this um I was just kind of
blown away when I saw some of the
results um okay so acknowledgements here
um of course you know there have been uh
nice support from variety of funding
agencies um and then these are of course
as we all know these are the people that
did the real work The Graduate students
um and I must to call out Dan because
that's uh really the the work came out
of his dissertation and we've been
collaborating ever since on this he's
now a director's postto fellow at uh at
lanel um and then uh just to the
references that we have here so if you
want the sort of uh 30,000 foot view of
this there's the S news article uh we
have a chapter in the handbook of
numerical analysis that goes into some
more of the technical details um this is
what we've managed to uh put out there
with Odes pdes interacting particle
systems online learning parameter
estimation reduced order models so sort
of it's really been quite uh productive
for us to to look at from this uh this
point of view um and then there's been
some more recent proposals actually this
one the red fourth reduced order model
paper has been uh accepted uh and then
there's these are the two things that
are in progress right now nonlinear
parameters and then also estimation for
the pdes and I think that's uh that's
all my that's the talk thank you oh
fascinating wonderful very nice um thank
you so much for the nice talk David uh
let's thank speaker let's have a Q&A
sessions um if you have questions please
unmute and ask
questions I have one question well I
several questions but um the first
question I would ask would be you know
that I I totally agree with you David
there will be so much more broad uh
applications where uh this Wix indd can
be used I mean you uh showed some
biolos the uh applications and um plasma
and and other uh partial differential
equations or Dynamics any other
applications in mind if you have funding
then I really want to apply this too
sure uh well so we actually so part of
the nihh money is do stochastic
differential equations too uh and we
have a couple of uh um this paper right
here does some stochastic differential
equations um we did deterministic
interacting particle systems in here so
we didn't we didn't do any of the
stochastic ones um and I think um this
one down no not that one uh this one
here is an ecology example which does
have some stochastics in it as
well and the reason why you want to go
there like this Focus um well so if you
think about doing a parameter estimation
for stochastic differential equations a
lot of the time you need to do a large
number of realizations of this of the
solutions to to sample it and when you
are uh if you have data either for like
an individual particle and is wandering
around we can do some estimation there
or if you have a collection of particles
that I didn't have it in this talk but
we've actually done some uh some things
with you know having like a couple
hundred particles wandering around and
you can very quickly identify the drift
and diffusion coefficients I mean this
some of the preliminary versions of this
go all the way back to the um the the
first week form papers uh from 2019 2021
that kind of stuff but yeah so that's so
that's that's an area that's really
compelling because it's sort of this uh
automatic upscaling is what you're kind
of doing um to get the the parameters
you need is is that answering your
question yeah can it be somehow useful
for the noise data as well the stas
stick with my should uh sure yeah so
that's so so it's a it's a question of
what's swamping what right and what's
the dominant uh uh how much do you know
like do you is it just brownie in motion
and then your observation is noisy also
um that's something you I mean you would
have to do some analysis to turn the
crank on it the the nice part about it
though is that you're again dealing with
a statistical regression system so there
are there's nonlinear regression you can
deal you can do things with there's
linear regression there's these errors
and variables problems so there's a lot
of uh it's it's a well-trod path that
simply I I feel like a lot of the times
we go look up some Advanced things in
literature and then not that the
theorems and the papers write themselves
but they are available to be discovered
um and it's less it's it's um just it's
just a a you know it's what you're
trained for when you do applied math
basically all right uh we have a Hands
Up by Amit Amit if you can yeah ask your
question um thanks than um thanks David
very nice talk um um I think one
particular application is what we are
trying to do in our group we are in the
physics division we are trying to
generate Continuum Scale Models directly
from atomistic data MH and the the hope
is that uh complexity associated with
the non- equilibrium process processes
effect of chemistry all of these can be
incorporated into the continum skill
models that we hope to learn from
atomistic data and um and I think
naturally they come out to be stochastic
differential equations so not we
initially we thought they they'll just
be PDS but it seems now that they'll be
SDS and the question or the couple of
questions that come up um are the
following and one one of them I actually
had mentioned what happens if you have
higher order time
derivatives uh present in your
dictionary and the second thing is that
um and you you show a lot of examples
but I wonder if you can comment on the
ability to learn nonlocal terms I mean
differential equations that have an
integral operator with a nonlocal c and
how how would noise in the input data
affect uh um the ability to reliably
learn such nonlocal terms okay
um I don't have a a direct answer for
you uh in terms of the non-local I know
we have done uh non-local terms in this
paper here uh we did sort of local and
non-local learning of the terms now we
we uh we made some assumptions about uh
what they look like but uh we definitely
have done that um in terms of the impact
of noise um I mean you're going to be
able to compute uh because again this is
coming from when you burrow right down
to the actual computation you end up
doing uh it's a regression and so you
can compute like krer raal bounds on how
accurate your estimates are going to be
um and in some sense we don't really
care whether or not it's local or
non-local as long as you have data to
support that so one of the things that
is uh pretty critical um let me go back
to this
here uh here so so for this particular
trajectory here like it's by itself
right and so you don't have a lot of
interactions with the nearby particles
or nearby cells there and so this is a
very challenging trajectory to learn and
so that was why our ad hoc
classification scheme started with the
trajectories that had a lot of
information content and then said okay
well what if we use one of these
trajectories here do we still get the
same one of these models here do we at
the same trajectory um and so I think
you're going to run into a question of
for the non-local interactions
especially do you do you have data that
supports the existence of a non-local
interaction um and and sort of just just
for learning it um is is that sort of
answering your question sure I think you
are you're pointing to a critical issue
which we are facing in a different
problem and the issue is about the
diversity of the of the training data
itself and how do we ensure that it's
uniformly distributed and is Rich enough
yeah I think I completely understand
okay perhaps we can have an
offline this is something very relevant
to what we are trying to okay great I
mean I there's um uh there are I have
seen a paper where they did some Quantum
hydrodynamics trying to upscale um it
was I don't know if it was data but it
was definitely at atomistic
simulations um and I'm happy to follow
up over email and send you that uh the
the article I know about um there's also
an ipam Workshop coming up next fall
that I'm helping to organize on
electrochemistry uh and and basically
trying to learn models for for
electrochemical interactions and such
and I can you know connect to you with
that uh that world as well if you if
that's of Interest sure thank you
awesome cool any other
questions I mean it's a 5f to 11 but um
if you have
questions I'm sure David is happy to
stay
longer no um all right if not let's
thank our speaker uh David and for the
wonderful talk and I'm sure um if you
have other questions you'll be happy to
get a email from you guys yeah please
please follow up happy to to to chat
about any of the the uh applications or
the the methods and such and also David
welcomes uh you know future
collaboration with you guys as well so
please contact David uh well with that
let me stop the record button